los ataques por motivos raciales
aumentaron en eeuu en la última década
la pandemia de ccoo y 19 por ejemplo
alimentó la violencia contra la
comunidad asiática en marzo de 2021 un
hombre de 21 años atacó tres salones de
masaje en atlanta dejando ocho muertos
entre ellos seis mujeres de origen
asiático los activistas afirman que las
declaraciones de donald trump presidente
durante el estallido de la crisis
sanitaria amplificaron el odio
cuando el presidente de eeuu llama al
coronavirus virus de china con club es
un insulto para todos nosotros los
asiáticos se están culpando de un virus
que no tiene nada que ver con nosotros
idiotas
en agosto de 2019 un hombre que se
declaró un militante de extrema derecha
desató una masacre de 23 personas en un
supermercado en texas le dijo a la
policía que quería matar a todos los
mexicanos posibles un año antes en 2018
un supremacista blanco irrumpió en una
sinagoga de pittsburgh y mató a tiros a
11 personas en el que se convirtió en el
ataque antisemita más mortífero de la
historia del país
está la escena del crimen más horrible
que he visto en 23 años en el fbi los
miembros de la sinagoga árbol de la vida
que realizaban un servicio pacífico en
su lugar de culto fueron brutalmente
asesinados por un hombre armado que los
tenía como objetivo simplemente por su
fe y en junio de 2015 un hombre de 21
años abrió fuego en una iglesia en
carolina del sur apagando la vida de
nueve afroamericanos en los últimos años
la llamada teoría del gran reemplazo ha
ido ganando terreno en eeuu la teoría
racista de la conspiración afirma que la
población blanca sería sustituida
gradualmente hasta su extinción por
inmigrantes no blancos
investigadores de los tiroteos masivos
descubrieron que ha inspirado a varios
autores de ataques